how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu so as i
mentioned
earlier today today was disney's third
quarter call
in this conference call they go over
finances and sometimes there's some
pretty big reveals about marvel
well i was on the q3 conference call i
just got off of it and there was
actually a pretty big reveal one that
could directly
impact marvel and the release of black
widow for those of you who were hoping
that black widow would go straight to
video on demand and streaming on disney
plus you may
actually get your wish i'll break down
what i heard in the conference call but
first if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the marvel news
and also so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a
gambit funko pop all you gotta do is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below
now to start off for the star wars fans
the mandalorian
season 2 has been confirmed to be coming
in october of this year so
everything with the mandalorian season 2
is still on track
they did announce that within the next
month they're going to be talking about
streaming announcements and i'll talk
more about what that means at the end
but they did drop a huge bomb and that
is that one of their
major films they had coming out this
year mulan is going straight to video on
demand on disney plus
so you will be able to watch mulan on
disney plus via what they call
premier access for 29.99
so 30 on september 4th you'll get to
watch milan now what does this mean for
black widow
well mulan was a huge project for disney
it was going to be an
absolutely incredible movie one that
they expected to make
a ton of money people thought there's no
way that this is going to go
straight to video on demand but now it
is and the same thing has been said
about black widow people said that
disney is no way thinking about
releasing these movies straight to video
on demand but now they
are and at the end when it was open for
questions somebody asked
if they're going to do this with black
widow as well
and this is exactly what bob chapek said
he said
we're very pleased to be able to bring
mulan to consumers we're fortunate that
we have the opportunity to bring it
direct
to our consumers we're looking at mulan
as a one-off
that said we find it very interesting to
take a new offering to consumers at
29.99 cost
and look at how much it drives
subscribers to disney plus plus the
video on demand
rentals he went on to say that they're
going to give it a try to recapture some
of the money that they've lost
they're going to learn and see if it
works and makes money if it makes money
from video on demand and also brings in
more subscribers to disney plus which
would also
make them a lot more money as well they
will consider doing it for other films
so basically what they just said is that
if mulan does
really well if it brings in a lot of
money and it brings in a lot of
subscribers to disney plus
they'll consider doing it for other
properties and if the theaters don't
open until 2021
this means that black widow will have a
very good chance at going straight
to video on demand now what does this
mean it doesn't mean that they are 100
going to put black widow straight to
video on demand but
right now a lot of the experts are
saying that they don't expect theaters
to open up until mid
2021 and in the earnings report they
obviously reported a very big loss for
the third quarter
so right now marvel and disney are just
sitting on this film that's already been
completed that's scheduled to come out
later on this year but movie theaters
aren't expected to be open so now there
actually is a relatively decent chance
that black widow will go straight to
video on demand because they just did it
for mulan which was going to be another
blockbuster film for them now as i said
in the beginning they specifically
mentioned that they're going to be doing
an investors call within a month to talk
about
streaming announcements so this would
likely be where they would talk about
any new
upcoming shows coming to disney plus
which of course would include the marvel
shows so if there is going to be any big
reveals it looks like they're going to
be revealed within the month
so stay tuned for that and be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on
anything
so it's a bummer that we may not get it
in theaters but at least we may not have
to wait that much longer for it but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below would you rather see
it in theaters
or would you rather be able to watch it
sooner than later paying 30
to watch it on disney plus let me know
what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof